welcome to the future of life institute
podcast i'm lucas perry
this is a special episode with fli
president max tegmark as well as with
our grants team andrea berman and daniel
phillin we're excited to announce a 25
million dollar multi-year grants program
the goal is to tip the balance towards
the flourishing of life and away from
extinction
this was made possible by the generosity
of cryptocurrency pioneer vitalik
buterin and the shiba inu cryptocurrency
community
you can find more information at
futureoflife.org
grant-programs or by tuning into the
rest of this episode and with that i'm
happy to have max tegmark introduce the
meaning and purpose of the grants
program
and andrea berman and daniel phillin
will give you more of the details
thanks so much for for coming on the on
the podcast max i'm really excited to be
getting your your perspective and story
on
uh the fli grants program that just
launched to start things off here i'm
curious if you could explain
what inspired you
to start this grants program
although there is a ton of money going
into artificial intelligence research
almost all of it is going into making ai
more powerful and almost none of it is
going into
making sure that we keep it safe and
keep it beneficial
and um i think people often have this
misguided
perspective where they think of
ai either as good or evil and like to
quibble about that when it's pretty
clear that artificial intelligence is a
tool
just like a knife or
a fire you know and the question isn't
whether it's good or evil it's just
morally neutral
whether it's good or bad depends on how
we use it
and uh
i think we have the potential to create
a really really inspiring future
for life
if
we win this wisdom race between the
growing power of the ai and the growing
wisdom with which we manage it i think
so far
we're not doing such a great job we're
seeing ai increasingly manipulate people
via social media
we're seeing ai going into all sorts of
increasingly sketchy uses
and there's still
quite the free-for-all on the legal side
and even on the technical side you know
so far
if your roomba accidentally
has a bug in it and falls down the
stairs
no big deal but we're putting ai in
charge of
ever more infrastructure and decisions
that affect people's lives from
courtrooms to
electrical grids
to
things that involve life and death and
hospitals right so it's crucial that we
don't just uh leave it to um people
outside of the technical fields to worry
about this but that those of us who are
really geeky nerdy like ai researchers
like myself also work hard on these
technical questions how can we build ai
systems
that actually do what we want them to do
and
how can we make them actually
trustworthy not because the sales
representative said we should trust it
or because we understand enough about
them
that we actually can trust them
how can we make sure that they actually
when they make decisions that involve
human lives that they have
been taught appropriate human
values or goals
these are
very difficult technical questions even
aside from the moral and ethical
ramifications and we need your help if
you are
an aspiring ai researcher to help solve
them
and so of the technological tools in the
21st century they're going to have major
impacts on human society as well as the
future of humanity and life where would
you rate ai technology in terms of its
potential impact and power
i would rate it that as the unchallenged
number
one all the other technologies were
invented using intelligence
using human intelligence so it's a
no-brainer that we if we can amplify
human intelligence
greatly with artificial intelligence
this is going to enable us to develop
all these other technologies
that we
would have otherwise taken way way
longer to do
faster instead and particularly if
ai succeeds in its initial goal which
you know was not just to make robotic
vacuum cleaners but to ultimately
do everything
the human mind can do
then
the most intelligent
entities on this planet are going to be
machines
and it will be incredibly naive to think
that we can just kind of build this
bumble into this future without any
planning and and the things are somehow
magically going to go well
the default is just disaster and i think
most likely just human extinction
that's why this program we're doing is
focused specifically on ai
existential safety
safety of systems that are
so powerful so smart in the future that
there there's not just this risk that
they're gonna
fall down the stairs or something but
they could end lead to the end of human
existence
when i was a kid a lot of people thought
that might be thousands of years away
now recent surveys show that most ai
researchers think it's decades away so
it's high time to
really turbo charge this research
given that this is
likely to be one of the most impactful
technologies of the 21st century if not
the most impactful technology what kind
of impact would you like the new fli
grants program to have
on
the development and outcomes of
artificial intelligence
the goal of this grants program is
not
to answer
all these crucial technical questions we
need answered but rather to
grow the talent pipeline to bring a lot
of talented idealistic people into this
field working on these technical issues
i find it um
quite ridiculous
if you just zoom out a little bit and
you think of this
beautiful
little blue spinning ball and space that
we all live on here almost 8 billion of
us with all these opportunities and all
these challenges
how few people are actually working
on this
arguably most important
challenge we face right there are way
way more people
who are working on ai just to optimize
how you can get
kids spending more time watching ads you
know how you can get more girls to
become anorexic from
watching unrealistic role models
in
and so on there are more people working
on those things
than on these incredibly fascinating
foundational questions of how you make
powerless powerful ai systems actually
safe and and beneficial and that's got
to change and i would like to see a
future where there's at least as much
talent going into working on ai safety
as there is on medical safety cancer
research and issues like this so we're
nowhere near there so what we want to
try to do is turbo charge this by
creating a series of grants we're
starting
with grants that can attract talented
undergrads to
go in and do their phd in computer
science
and
likewise take people who are
finishing their phd in computer science
go and do a really nice well-paid
postdoc in nai safety
in the hope that these people will soon
become professors and
work at companies where they can go um
in turn mentor and supervise
a whole new round of
of talent
so that this field can rapidly grow to
the size that it
needs to be
so as a
lifelong
scientist and someone passionate about
the the mystery of the universe you've
you know long been exposed to
uh and experienced talent pipelines
since you know before you
became a professor but then also
during your time as a professor so you
have quite a lot of experience with with
grants so i i'm curious if you could
explain some
experience in your lifetime where you
received a grant that
was really important and crucial and
helpful to you to helping to work on
problems that you found most exciting
and important and
how your experience with with grants in
general in your life informs
this grants process at the future of
life institute
yeah it's amazing how much difference
the grant can make and how much
difference it made in fact in my life i
i remember when i was a grad student um
when i was a postdoc i had uh
pretty eclectic interest that was there
were some things i felt were just really
really important to work on and
many of my peers
especially many of my most of my senior
peers thought were just bs and then i
got this amazing grant this particular
one was from the packard foundation it's
called the packard fellowship
and what was so amazing with it about it
was it let me do
just but
exactly the research i was passionate
about
for five years
and it had more impact on my career than
any other funding ever and it enabled me
to just focus on doing what my heart was
on fire about and i happen to believe
that
not only is it more fun and fulfilling
to work on something you really believe
in hey you know
again if we get this one shot to live on
this planet you should we should make it
count and and follow our heart right
but it also the case that we do much
better work that when we work
on what we were passionate about and my
message to you if if
you are someone watching this if you
love ai if you love computer science you
want to work on it but you're concerned
that it's not going to be safe or
beneficial and you want to make a
difference
my message to you is you can really make
a career out of this this is not the
case where you have to choose between a
well-paid successful career on one hand
and your heart on the other hand you can
really have both
thanks to various other funders like the
open philanthropy project there's
already a lot of grant money available
for this kind of ai safety if you're a
professor
the problem is there are almost no
professors do this
they're
and that's what this is trying to change
if you go into this field now and become
a world leading expert on
ai existential safety there will be
an amazing career ahead of you and you
can help mentor others
continue realizing a lot of the vision
that you don't have time to finish with
all by yourself
so it's a great career move
and it's incredibly rewarding because
you you know when you do this
that you are actually working on
what i believe is a single most crucial
fork in the road that humanity has ever
faced you know we've spent 13.7 13.8
billion years on this planet being
basically uh
subject to the whims of nature you know
now there's a drought um
now there's a hurricane there's nothing
we can do about any of this to the point
where
we have become so empowered by our
technology that we can either
use it to ruin our planet
chop finish chopping down the rest of
the rain forest you know mess up our
climate uh treated massacre
other people other species or
we can use it to create
a future where life flourishes like
never before
it's so obvious that technology has this
innate ability to enable flourishing and
why is it that
the life expectancy now is not 30 years
anymore
because of technology
why is it that most of you watching this
are not worried about starving to death
in your life or
dying of pneumonia and
because
there's technology right and the
technology today is very limited by our
own intelligence as humans our ability
to invent the cure for cancer and many
other things
with artificial intelligence it's quite
clear that if we get this right we're
not going to be limited by our own
abilities anymore we're going to be
limited just
eventually by the laws of nature because
artificial intelligence that's
beneficial
and aligned with our values will enable
us to get through all these roadblocks
and and um
enable a truly inspiring future
not just for the next election cycle but
for billions of years and maybe not just
on earth either but throughout much of
this this amazing cosmos
this grants program basically is a is a
portal where you can go through and
help
bring about this inspiring future do you
have any inspiring futures the
the that speak to your heart that you'd
be interested in in sharing
i try to be very humble about the
question about exactly how the future
should be and i would very much not like
to micromanage future generations
but i would very much like
to give those future generations the
opportunity to exist in the first place
now we have been so reckless with our
tech so far that we've almost
obliterated earth with an accidental
nuclear war a bunch of times and if we
build
artificial general intelligence without
solving these crucial technical problems
it's overwhelmingly likely that
some small click of humans is going to
just use that to take power over the
whole rest of the planet if anyone
watching this isn't worried about that i
would encourage you to just take
30 seconds and just visualize the face
of your least favorite
leader on this planet
you don't have to tell anyone who it is
and just imagine that now they control
everything
if that doesn't make you feel great
then
i think you're on board with this vision
that this great power that ai can
unleash should not be given to that
person it should be given to humanity we
should create
we should figure out a way of using this
technology to empower everybody to
create a good future
and we do not have
the answers to how to do that yet
in order to be able to really answer
your question lucas is about how should
our society be organized or should we
have a very pluralistic world where
different people in different
corners of the world can do things their
own way and experiment
as long as they
don't go kill
everybody else you know respect the
pluralism
how this all gets played out
i want to be humble and and
and
defer to to
this to help work it out but a
prerequisite to even be able to have
that conversation that is that we can
control the technology itself
again and have it safe beneficial and
start thinking through these these hard
questions about how you can even make ai
that can understand human values
learn them and retain them
so
as we wrap up here do you have any final
words for
anyone who might be listening that's
considering applying to this grants
program but you know isn't quite sure or
um
you know
does ai but isn't sure that
ai alignment or ai existential risk
research is really the right path what
is it that you might say or share with
someone like that
if you're considering any kind of career
and you're not sure you should go find
people who are in the career already and
just talk to them a bit see what it's
like
and we've created an ai existential
safety community page which will be
linked from this video where you can see
a bunch of friendly faces of
professors around the world who are
working on this
maybe one of them can be your mentor for
your phd your postdoc
reach out to people like that and
talk to them ask them what they do ask
them why they're excited about it ask
them if they're taking on students or
postdocs ask them um if they would like
to have you as
a free postdoc or a free grad student
because that's what it's going to be
like to them if you come with our
fellowship
all right excellent max i think you did
a really wonderful job of conveying how
there are
you know few few issues which measure up
to the impact and scale of this and so
you know thank you for that
thank you lucas and with that i'm happy
to introduce daniel and andrea who will
give you more details about the grants
welcome to the podcast andrea and daniel
it's great to have you here and i'm
excited to be speaking about our grants
program andrew could you tell us a
little bit about what the grants program
is we are especially focused on
supporting collaboration amongst people
thinking about these topics and we are
excited to collaborate with everyone
we are
also excited about uh addressing the
talent pipeline and supporting more
people to um especially
people early in their career to get into
studying existential risk we're looking
at
supporting policy and advocacy
behavioral science
and the aix essential
safety program which has already
launched and that's what daniel is
leading
in particular in the ais sexual safety
aspect we're really interested in work
um
it's about analyzing ways in which ai
could
you know
cause some kind of existential
catastrophe for humanity agendas for
research that could reduce this
existential risk and of course people
who are actually doing it
reducing the existential risk not
causing it we will not fund that
exactly daniel could you tell me a
little bit more about when the deadline
is how people can apply and who it's for
yeah so we have two specific um
uh fellowships on offer right now so the
first is a phd fellowship so this is
um as we mentioned for people working on
uh technical aspects of ai essential
safety
um we're in particular targeting it at
people who are just starting their phd
in 2022
so applying this season to start next
year
um
and we are also
interested in funding people who are
already in their phd and want to be
working on ai extensional safety but
like perhaps don't have the funding to
work on that particular topic
um
we're trying to
i don't know i think we're being
somewhat generous where we have a
stipend of forty thousand dollars for
people in the uk or canada if people are
shortlisted
we are going to pay for some of their
application fees to universities and
also uh we'll invite them to an
information session about which places
might be good to work on it the deadline
is october 29th um 2021
um including the day of october the 29th
um for the application and letters of
recommendation have to come in by
november 5th so that's the phd
fellowship we also have a postdoctoral
fellowship so if you're
you know if you just graduated from a
phd and want to do a postdoc or maybe
you're moving in from industry or a
different field i think this could be a
pretty good option for you
um
in this case uh it's obviously a higher
stipend uh eighty thousand dollars for
people in the us uk or canada
and uh the deadline for that one is
november the 5th
is is there a total amount uh that is on
offer uh between these two programs well
i guess we shouldn't spend more than 25
million dollars but i actually don't
have a particular budget um i think
we're pretty
i think we're pretty excited to support
you know as many people as it makes
sense to um
we'll see we'll see how it goes so if
you're if your application is excellent
then you should apply uh anyways yeah i
don't think we expect to run out of
money for really good applicants
okay great um and it sounded like
there's also this uh ai
uh existential risk uh community that's
also being developed yeah so could you
also tell me a little bit about that
one aspect of making work happen in this
space
is just like publicizing who's
interested in
work particularly focused on reducing
existential risk
so i think people have a good sense of
like
who's interested in natural language
processing or who's interested in
reinforcement learning in ai um
and you might have some sense of who's
interested in you know
work on safety in general
but it can be a little bit less clear um
which professors are really interested
in
you know supervising work
specifically on existential safety so
what we've done is we you know have this
form that professors can fill out to
tell us like why they're interested um
and we'll feature some people on our
website who we think would you know
they're interested in supervising work
in this field we think they'd make good
supervisors um just so that for one
students can find them and
for two that like other professors can
know who's in this space
yeah i really love the idea of this
community
in terms of increasing the transparency
of who's working on what i would have
loved that in in undergrad because it
seems like a lot of what you need here
is uh to basically be already in the
community or pretty adjacent to it to
get the the transparency into seeing
who who's working on what so um
i really love the idea of this community
um
and so you know here we've discussed the
the ai existential risk grant program um
but you know as we mentioned there will
be you know phases or um
uh grant programs that are also focused
on reducing
existential risk um so
andrea could you tell me a little bit
about um these uh future programs that
will be used with the um
these future programs that will be
created with the uh
generous donation from
the vitalik buterin and the shiba inuk
uh cryptocurrency community
we at fli
have a
policy team which is currently in the
midst of um
developing its new policy priorities
that will
inform what our grant making priorities
will be as well
we hope that we will
announce
both our internal and grit making
priorities
in early 2022
at which point we anticipate making a
range of grants both some research
grants
and some
fellowships to address the talent
pipeline and we also anticipate
grants addressing um
behavioral science again
most likely research grants as well as
fellowship grants and we also are in
plans to
announce
soon some uh
some grants related to the future of
life awards
which will um
be a great opportunity to not only
support
the
big award winners but
those people that may have
helped support their work along the way
or may have helped
highlight their work to us so that we
could be able to celebrate them
so
we are excited about putting this um
this large donation to good use and
thinking about
innovative and creative ways that we can
um
make grants
and
i think one of the threads that runs
amongst all our grants is as i mentioned
earlier we really want to collaborate
with others um
we've already been talking about talking
with other funders about ways that we
can collaborate with them on uh
supporting
individuals and
organizations in this space and just
forming better connections with
all of the people that are working in
the space or want to be working in the
space is a great way
to feed the ecosystem and and and expand
it so
um
that is is an exciting thing
yeah so so speaking of of exciting
things i i'm curious what you're both
you know looking back over
all these different things that are on
offer what are you both most excited
about and
hopeful for these these grants going
into the future uh daniel would you like
to start off
yeah if i had to pick one thing i think
the idea of somebody who's like
heard you know just heard of this idea
that like maybe you can do technical
work to like reduce the chance that
humanity goes extinct related to ai they
like go to fli's website they see like
oh here's some professors who are
interested in working on this topic too
um they like you know get some fli
fellowship and they like go on to do
amazing work uh i think like
you know that really might happen i
think we've got a good shot of making
that happen and if it did i think that
would be fantastic so it's probably
number one exciting thing for me
and
i um
i am just a love lover of learning new
things so um already in the last couple
of months i've i've learned a lot about
existential risk i've been able to
connect with a lot of um
applicants and prospective applicants um
to help them
with
their their applications and and
thinking through how they're going to um
answer all the questions that we have we
really
do like daniel said there's a lot of uh
potential great people out there and we
want to be able to
support them and we
want to be as accessible and helpful
throughout the process as we can be
and so if listeners are interested in
applying or getting more information or
checking out when the deadlines are
where can they do that
they can visit our website
at grants.futureoflife.org
there's all the information about our
current grant
opportunities there and it will be
updated as the other opportunities i
mentioned are rolled out
they can also always email us at grants
futureoflife.org with any questions they
have well you know thank you so much
andrea and daniel for for coming on um
if you have any last
parting words
of encouragement for the the listeners
um maybe to help motivate them to to
apply um or check out the website um
here's a space for you to share that
start with you daniel i mean i don't
really know who's listening to this so i
can't i can't say anything super
specific but i don't know at least check
it out who knows could be good fit you
never know you could save the world
[Music]